I will e-mail you blood results when I get them back, but my hemoglobin is 8.3.
So when you talk about ademia, you want to look at your red blood cell cunt, like this
question up here, you're looking at iron saturation, ferritin, and then you're looking at red cell
with RDW or there's other things that you're looking at to find out what type of ademia it is.
But when you're really talking about concerns with ademia, you're really talking about
hemoglobin.
So that's your biggest concern as far as how many symptoms you're going to have from
ademia.
That's all you'd really need to look at as far as how is it affecting my life?
Because your hemoglobin drops down, especially if it drops down into the 8s or the 7s
or lower, then you're going to start having some fatigue.
So like, when you said your hemoglobin is still at 10, you might not really be experiencing
a whole lot of symptoms at that point.
But when your hemoglobin starts to drop down into the 8s and the 7s and the 6s, that's
what you're going to really start feeling some fatigue.
And this goes back to that same question about iron, demand to be careful with iron.
Yes, and no, as you're certainly with the hemoglobin of the low 8s, you definitely want
to start iron, but you want to add artimicidin.
And I know who asked this question, please schedule a time to talk with me tomorrow because
I want to talk to you about some other things.
I'm taking prohydroxychobolamine.
So prohydroxychobolamine is the B12 component if part of your anemia is tied to B12 anemia.
So there's different types of anemia.
It can be anemia of chronic disease, which you usually see in cancer patients because the
cancer is kind of gobbled up the iron.
But you could also have anemia B12 anemia, and that is a totally different component that
really is a comorbidity of cancer patients.
It's not a cause of B12 anemia is necessarily tied to any causation of cancer.
This is the artimicidin that I'd recommend, you know, we just in general, it's research,
it's racial artimicidin, solo, and if you're in general, if you're going to take one capsule
of my or take one to two of these, if you're going to take a couple, if you're going to take
iron a couple times a day with certainly with hemoglobin in the 8s, you'd want to take clear
iron, probably three a day, then you take three to six are the artimicidin.
So you take one to two of these every time you take an iron capsule.